bonsoir françois durpaire merci d'être
avec nous alors vous avez dit un chez
nos confrères de la dépêche
plus un acte de re révolution que des
émeutes
ça veut dire quoi françois durpaire ça
veut dire que depuis le début de ce de
ces cycles de rébellion la presse
américaine et qualifie toujours cela de
wired
c'est à dire des meutes pour les
disqualifier alors même que l'histoire
de ces rébellions noire dans l'histoire
des états unis
et bien c'est beaucoup de sit in et une
inventivité très très forte c'est sont
aussi ce qu'on appelle des marches sont
aussi ce qu'on appelle des des freedom
ride il ya énormément de pacifisme mais
souvent les médias au cours de
l'histoire ont occulté tout cela montrer
uniquement les images de violence et on
qualifier ça de riot d'émeutes
alors même que la rébellion est au socle
de la démocratie américaine depuis la
boston tea party et vous avez vu
d'ailleurs que le président trunk il ya
quelques semaines a même appelé à la
rébellion mais il pensait que c'était
une bonne rébellion pour libérer le
minnesota pour libérer le michigan mais
c'était à l'époque contre les
gouverneurs démocrates alors l'onu a
condamné aujourd'hui une discrimination
raciale les discriminations raciales
dans le pays
hier c'était le basketteur michael
jordan qui est sorti de ce légendaire
réserve pour parler d'un racisme ancré
aux états unis vous qui connaissez par
coeur ce pays
quelle est votre réaction alors est ce
qu'il ya un racisme plus important aux
états unis qu'ailleurs et notamment en
france je pense que vous avez entendu
les propos les propos du préfet de
police de paris il ya quelques minutes
sur votre antenne et vous aurez votre
réponse
l'amérique n'est pas plus raciste que la
france mais simplement il y a aux etats
unis la volonté de s'en sortir
complètement et je vais vous parler
brièvement du témoignage d'un homme très
important puisque c'est l'ancien maire
de minneapolis a au petit bac et il dit
quoi aujourd'hui dans la presse il dit
j'ai failli à ma tâche
j'ai failli à ma tâche parce que
j'aurais dû réformer la police
qu'est ce que j'aurais dû faire
démilitariser la police mieux former les
policiers faire au sida police de
proximité mais dit il et c'est ça le
plus important
tout cela ne servira à rien si nous
américains blancs le prenons pas
conscience d'une chose c'est la culture
de la peur c'est à dire qu'il y à du
danger pour les noirs à se déplacer dans
les rues américaines parce que les
blancs considère les noirs comme
dangereux vous voyez le cycle mortifère
je vous rappelle d'un mot simplement qu
aux etats unis
lorsque vous êtes un noir armés vous
êtes abattu parce que lorsque vous êtes
un noir non armé
vous êtes abattu par la police comme
quand vous êtes un blanc armés vous êtes
arrêtés et menottés et dans tout ça
donne un tram qui semble souffler sur
les braises le président américain qui
se revendique aujourd'hui encore
président de la loi et de l'ordre
jusqu'où cette escalade peut aller donne
un tram dit je suis la loi et l'ordre
mais vous vous rappelez que c'est sa
campagne électorale de 2016 je suis le
candidat de l'ordre c'était sa campagne
c'est pas sous barack obama qu'il y a eu
de cette vague nationale en revanche il
ya effectivement eu des graves problèmes
sous barack obama blacklight matin et
des sous barack obama mais pas ce
mouvement national alors ce qu'il faut
bien souligner c'est que aujourd'hui
donald trump avec certains de ses
conseillers veut l'emporter à la nixon
en 1968 qui avait dit je vais appeler la
majorité silencieuse ces américains qui
restent chez eux qui ne sont pas dans la
rue vont voter pour moi la seule
différence est que nixon n'étais pas
président qu'il était candidat de
l'ordre
mais quand on est président en vient on
est comptable et ça veut dire que
beaucoup d'américains n'ont pas chez les
républicains qui voteront donald trump
non pas chez les démocrates qui de toute
façon votre on the maiden mais chez les
indépendants et bien on se posera la
question est ce que ce n'est pas un
président du désordre vous savez
aujourd'hui l'amérique est polarisée
quand on est républicain on est plus
inquiet par les images de violences
urbaines que par l'image de cet homme
tué de manière raciste
lorsqu'on est démocrate celle inverse on
est plus préoccupé par le raciste que
peut être ces émeutes dans la rue mais
lorsqu'on est indépendant c'est à dire
le vent
entre mou de la politique américaine et
c'est eux qui vont faire l'élection on
est très occupée par les deux images à
la fois par la violence raciste des
policiers de certains policiers mais
aussi par la violence de certains
émeutiers et donc celui qui arrivera à
faire un discours d' équilibre pour
aller chercher ces gens qui sont
préoccupés par les deux est bien celui
là
arrivera à gagner l'élection le 3
novembre prochain sauf qu'aujourd'hui il
ya une crise économique gravissime il ya
ces émeutes dont on parle
comment on va s'en sortir s'il n'y a
aucun leader qui cherche à apaiser la
situation de part et d'autre vous l'avez
vous l'avez dit le problème il est avant
tout économique c'est un problème
économique certains disent que c'est
l'année la pire de l'histoire moderne
des états unis vous à la fois un bilan
humain on parle de 2001 pour les pour le
world trade center mais là c'est un
bilan 30 fois supérieur cent mille morts
on parle de la grande dépression ou là
aussi cette année avec 40 millions de
chômage et 1968
les révoltes urbaines on les a aussi une
année donc extrêmement difficile
malcom x 10 et vous le savez le rêve
américain c'est pour certains mais nous
nous vivons le cauchemar américain et le
cauchemar américain à minneapolis il est
très très clair vous avez une différence
de 47 mille dollars entre un ménage
noire et un ménage blanc quand vous
pensez aux coronavirus dans l'état du
minnesota que je prends en exemple c'est
celui d'où tout est parti
6 % de personnes atteintes du
coronavirus mais si vous êtes un noir
américain 30 % et enfin si vous êtes né
aux amis de minneapolis et bien si vous
êtes né à minneapolis
vous avez 13 fois plus de risques d'être
tué par la police de votre ville que si
vous êtes un citoyen blanc sans rapport
avec la criminalité
les recherches ont montré qu'il n'y a
pas de lien entre la criminalité s'il
faut le dire et être noir d'ailleurs la
preuve il ya des quartiers noirs aisé
aux états unis ils sont pas touchées par
la criminalité
merci françois durpaire spécialiste
des états unis merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france